[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer donnerstag
haben sie sind es wir sind es auch das
finden wir gut so hier sind unsere gäste
und das ist unser thema lockern in der
pandemie verrückt oder überfällig gute
frage jetzt jedenfalls noch nicht sagt
der bundesgesundheitsminister aber haben
die menschen noch geduld um uns herum in
europa wird überall geöffnet und auch in
deutschland verlieren politiker langsam
die nerven statt zweig braucht es nur
noch masken und bei der impfpflicht
knirscht es gewaltig bayern stellt sich
quer und der bundesjustizminister nimmt
das wort tyrannei in den mut warum das
kann er uns gleich erklären unsere gäste
marco buschmann der
bundesjustizminister sagt wenn
regierende aussuchen an welche gesetze
sie sich halten ist tyrannei nicht mehr
fern
klaus holetschek der bayerische
gesundheitsminister erklärt die pflege
impfpflicht können wir noch nicht
umsetzen
stephan weil der spd-ministerpräsident
kritisiert bayern ist zum
unberechenbaren faktor geworden
johannes wimmer der mediziner sagt schon
jetzt kann man auf viele maßnahmen
verzichten
helga rübsamen chef die virologin warnt
für lockerungen ist es noch zu früh
und lykke friis die dänische
politikwissenschaftlerin sagt
deutschland könnte viel von uns lernen
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner und
die begrüßte gäste
unsere formen herzlich danke dass sie
mit dabei sind die ärzte und pfleger
müssen geimpft sein da war sich die
politik ausnahmsweise mal einig dass
progression
er ist der verwandlungskünstler der
deutschen politik aus team vorsicht wird
jetzt kurzerhand
team schreck lass nach
bayern setzt die impfpflicht aus was vor
landtagswahlen zählt so dass feines
gespür für stimmungen
[Musik]
deswegen haben arbeiten wir daran
großzügige übergangsregelungen was de
facto auf einen zunächst mal ein
aussetzen des vollzugs hinausläuft
die abkehr der einrichtung bezogenen
impfpflicht ist aus meiner sicht
verantwortungslos und auch
rücksichtslose parteipolitische taktik
noch letzten freitag hatte so das eigene
staatskanzlei auf die umsetzung der
impfpflicht gepocht und jetzt
simsalabim übernimmt sogar die
cdu-führung söders rolle rückwärts dass
wir die bundesregierung auffordern den
vollzug der einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht die ab dem 15 dritten jetzt
gesetzlich angeordnet ist auszusetzen
das chaos ist programmiert
denn andere in der union halten an der
in der pflicht fest während werden in
schleswig-holstein de kurs halten
insbesondere der schutz von arabien
gruppen steht jetzt im mittelpunkt
marco buschmann ist bei uns der
bundesjustizminister herr buschmann der
bund legt ein gesetz fest ein land will
sich nicht daran halten geht das so
einfach ist der freistaat so frei nein
die
staatliche gewalt ist überall in
deutschland ein recht und gesetz
gebunden
bundesrecht bricht auch landesrecht in
dem fall liegt aber auch gar keine
kollision vor und ich bin mir sehr
sicher dass die juristen in der
staatskanzlei herrn söder mittlerweile
aufgeklärt haben und ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass natürlich ihr bundesrecht
vollzogen werden wird
andererseits gibt es auch möglichkeiten
das durchzusetzen er ist auf dem weg in
die türen ein
naja das ist ein begriff den ich gewählt
habe aber den halten einige für eine
zuspitzung nur ein gedanke ist ja völlig
klar wenn man dreieinhalb tausend jahre
ab ländliche staatsphilosophie sich
anschaut dann ist der schritt zur
tyrannei immer dann wenn sich die
inhaber der macht selber aussuchen ob
sie sich an gesetze halten oder nicht
und ich finde und das ist mir wirklich
wichtig wir erleben jetzt vermehrt dass
immer wieder leute meinen mit
begründungen des notstandes oder weil
sie eine höhere einsicht haben das für
sie scheinbar recht nicht gelten würde
das geht nicht wir haben hier ein gesetz
beschlossen und dieses gesetz ist
übrigens von der gesamten landesgruppe
der csu mit beschlossen worden weil wir
nämlich 570 jahr stimmen am 10 dezember
dafür hatten für das bundesrat klaglos
bundesrat und deshalb es ist völlig da
ist ein geltendes gesetz das muss zur
anwendung kommen unabhängig davon ob
einem das persönlich gefällt denn wir
leben immer noch in einem rechtsstaat
und meine aufgabe als justizminister ist
es dafür zu sorgen dass das auch so
bleibt so das können sie jetzt auch
direkt klaus holetschek sagen dem
gesundheitsminister des freistaates
bayern herr hologic ist es so dass wir
mit alten und kranken arbeitet künftig
geimpft sein muss außer in bayern
nein das ist nicht so ich will aber erst
mal sagen hat buschmann vergreift sich
natürlich vollkommen in der wortwahl
davon tyrannei oder irgendetwas zu
sprechen ist er völlig fehl am platz wir
haben gesagt der vollzug dieses gesetzes
ist einfach so nicht möglich dieses
gesetz hat den praxis check wenn sie so
wollen nicht überstanden und deswegen
haben wir den finger in eine wunde
gelegt wo er auch hingehört da sind so
viele offene fragen und das haben wir an
den bundesgesundheitsminister adressiert
übrigens alle länder am 22 januar schon
wir haben gebeten vollzugshinweise zu
geben klare leitplanken zu setzen die
frage wäre es denn betroffen von dem
gesetz und es sind so viele fragen offen
unsere landräte oberbürgermeister die
einrichtungen haben alle noch einmal
deutlich gemacht so kann es nicht
funktionieren
und die findet es mehr als vernünftig
dann zu sagen wir müssen da
übergangszeiten nochmal anschauen und
müssen sehen wie wir da gemeinsam
zurechtkommen die pflicht die
impfpflicht stellen wir nicht in frage
und wir werden uns natürlich im rahmen
von recht und gesetz bewegen da kann ich
habe schon beruhigen es ist ja auch noch
sind ja auch noch fünf wochen zeit und
nun sagt der cdu ministerpräsident von
schleswig-holstein das hinkriegt herr
weil wird gleich sagen dass er es
hinkriegt nur die bayern nicht es bayern
auf dem weg irgendwie zum failed state
ach nein aber wissen sie die
gesundheitsämter vor ort sind überlastet
und wenn ich das ja heute lese dass zb
die niedersächsische
krankenhausgesellschaft auch sagt es
sind viele fragen noch offen und die
länderminister an dieses jahr gemeinsam
adressiert an sind halt auch dinge noch
zu klären und es muss halt jetzt
passieren und ich finde es richtig dass
wir das jetzt tun und es ist auch
richtig dass ein ministerpräsident sagt
moment stoppt da ist etwas im gange war
es noch nicht funktioniert und wir
wollen ein gesetz auch richtig
vollziehen das es ankommt und das haben
wir gesagt und deutlich gemacht nun gab
es 17 seiten des
bundesgesundheitsministers die schon mal
versucht haben ein bisschen dabei zu
helfen und durchführungs hinweise zu
geben mal unabhängig davon stephan weil
ministerpräsident des landes
niedersachsen
würden sie sagen jetzt kommen die
niedersächsischen pfleger dann in
schwabing an in münchen schwabing weil
sich da auch welche nicht impfen lassen
wollen befürchten sie dass da jetzt als
nächstes so eine art tourismus
stattfindet viele könnten nicht sein wir
wissen dass in niedersachsen allenfalls
fünf prozent der betroffenen in der
pflege noch nicht geimpft sind wir gehen
davon aus dass viele in den nächsten
wochen und monaten erfolgen werden das
zeigen auch andere beispiele
und sie werden ganz bestimmt nicht nach
bayern gehen weil sie nämlich den wert
einer stetigen regierungstätigkeit zu
würdigen wissen also insofern sehe ich
diese einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht
gelassen entgegen und ich wünsche mir
sehr dass man in bayern allmählich zur
selbstkritik fähig ist und dann auch
vielleicht das ganze mal wieder ein
bisschen runter zu und meine befürchtung
ist dass der ansonsten von mir
geschätzte kollege markus söder
demnächst einer der populärsten
politiker auf querdenker die muss sein
wird denn das was er gemacht hat spielt
den wirklich in die karten und das ist
das was mich am meisten aufregt bei
dieser posse muss man ja sagen letzten
tage hier sind zwei politiker richtig
führten checa
ich kann ihnen sagen spielt den
querdenker mehr in die hände wenn ein
gesetz nicht vernünftig vollzogen werden
kann und wissen sie wenn ich jetzt sehe
dass wir nächste woche im bundestag
nicht über die allgemeine impfpflicht
diskutieren das noch einmal verschieben
auf ende märz obwohl wir gesagt haben
die einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
ist nur der erste schritt für die
allgemeine dann frage ich mich schon wo
wir denn die mit dem finger hin zeigen
denn das wundert mich wenn sie sagen
dass sie nicht mal eine einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht durchführen und
durchsetzen können wie sie dann eine
allgemeine impfpflicht durchsetzen
wollen das ist schon eine etwas
wunderliche argumentationen und die
dinge haben glaube ich nicht so viel
miteinander zu tun und sagen sie doch
noch einzelne checkt bayern war immer so
stolz auf seine verwaltungskompetenz
warum sind sie nicht in der lage etwas
durchzusetzen was in schleswig holstein
und niedersachsen möglich zu sein
scheint aber das sind wir doch aber die
umsetzung wirft doch fragen auf
ministerpräsident wir haben doch in den
gesundheitsämtern das wissen sie doch
auch vor ort die frage wann ist ein
tätigkeitsverbot ein
beschäftigungsverbot einzugehen wie ist
es überhaupt mit der anhörung in welche
richtung geht die wäre es denn überhaupt
betroffen es sind doch noch viele fragen
offen auch meine kollegin die sehr
schätze aus niedersachsen hat doch am 22
januar gemeinsam mit der gmk noch mal
das riecht und bundesgesundheitsminister
adressiert und da muss man halt auch
liefern nicht mehr und nicht weniger wir
sollten alle wieder ein stück weit
runter kommen da haben sie sicherlich
recht aber dass dort noch nachholbedarf
ist und das noch nachjustiert werden
muss und es wirklich sinnvoll umzusetzen
das ist aus meiner sicht völlig klar und
wir haben auch der branche gesagt die
allgemeine impfpflicht wird kommen und
jetzt schieben wir dieses projekt von
einem tag auf den anderen da wäre ein
regierungsentwurf gut gewesen und auch
die führung des kanzlers und trotzdem
frage ich nochmal nach diesen seiten 17
seiten die es gegeben hat vom
bundesgesundheitsminister da wurde im
übrigen erklärt wer alles gemeint ist
und gemeint ist für diese einrichtung
bezogenen impfpflicht es wurde auch
erklärt welchen ermessenspielraum die
länder haben und dass man sich durchaus
bewusst ist dass das nicht zeitlich
alles am 15.3 passiert weil die
gesundheitsämter einfach überlastet sind
wo sind denn ihre fragen noch her weil
die sie dringend geklärt sehen möchten
und sagen da brauchen wir jetzt wirklich
richtlinien des bundes also wenn nichts
kommt dann wenn bürger niedersachsen
alleine in der lage sein das gesetz
umzusetzen aber wir wünschen uns dass
wir in dieser frage wirklich zu
einheitlichen maßstäben kommen und da
sind wesentliche grundzüge tatsächlich
jetzt schon beantwortet also es beileibe
nicht so dass das gesetz nicht anwendbar
wäre aber es gibt sicherlich noch viele
spezialfragen die kennt hologic im
zweifel besser als ich wo es gut wäre
wenn der bund jetzt noch mal sagen würde
da geht's lang und es wäre noch besser
weil dann anschließend auch alle länder
sagen würden ok und so machen wir es
auch wenn sich darüber einig werden dann
bin ich sicher dann kommt man schnell
zum ziel johannes wimmer ist bei uns
humanmediziner bekannt aus dem fernsehen
und von youtube sollten alle ärzte und
ärztinnen und alle pfleger und
pflegerinnen geimpft sein also was mich
wundert ist dass diese diskussion sich
anhört als hätten wir jetzt seit drei
wochen eine pandemie also wir sind jetzt
zwei jahre drüber und reden als wäre
sozusagen ein akuter notstand wo jetzt
wirklich handlungsbedarf auch gewesen
wäre also ich muss sagen für mich ist
mein bauchgefühl die diskussion jetzt
mit der impfpflicht und jetzt in monaten
darüber abzustimmen das ist ja so viel
zu spät auch wenn man sich die
entwicklung des der virus varianten
anschaut und wie sich generell diese
sozusagen pandemie in einer ende militär
entwickelt dann ist es eigentlich also
eigentlich kann ich jeden verstehen der
sagt ich komme mit der politik gar nicht
hinterher es wird sich gestritten über
dinge als würden wir drüber reden steht
jetzt ein windkraftrad ein kilometer
oder fünf kilometer von meinem haus
entfernt wo man sich gerne streiten kann
aber wir verlieren ja völlig den bezug
zu der gemeinschaft und zu der
gesellschaft die wirklich nicht mehr
folgen kann also nicht befolgen sie
sagen die größte dummheit war dass wir
es nicht schon viel früher gemacht naja
also die impfpflicht hätte wirklich was
bewirkt und ich bin mir sicher sie hätte
tausende leben gerettet wenn wir sie in
der sekunde wo der impfstoff wirklich
verfügbar war erstens dass wir noch
impfstoff gehabt hätten ist ja schon
damit an dass nicht nur masken hatten in
der sekunde war da war hätten wir es
eigentlich durchsetzen müssen dann hätte
es ein effekt gehabt jetzt sind
mittlerweile das kennt jeder aus seinem
bekanntenkreis alle möglichen leute die
gebucht sind sind wiederholt schon
teilweise omikron positiv die raten
gehen ganz stark nach unten wir sprechen
nicht mehr von einer derartigen
überlastung des gesundheitssystems
systems gemacht haben es ist einfach das
vertrauen und das ist das große problem
wir leben in einer gesellschaft die
eigentlich eine impfbereitschaft hat ich
glaube die wehr viel höher wenn wir sie
die gesellschaft auch früher die leute
mit ins boot geholt hätten dann haben
wir aber nicht es gibt große studie
mittlerweile das vertrauen der
hauptfaktor ist dafür das kunstwerk muss
wären wir gleich eine kollegin aus
dänemark es gibt einen herrlichen spruch
aus dänemark es gibt nur eine sache wie
besser ist als eine impfpflicht nämlich
eine gesellschaft die keine braucht und
wir haben uns leider dahin entwickelt
dass wir jetzt über eine impfpflicht
sprechen wurde der zug einzig abgefahren
interessanter punkt bei helga rübsamen
chef ist bei uns das finden wir auch in
dieser sendung ausgesprochen klasse aus
düsseldorf wieder zugeschaltet ist in
rom im nikon zeiten für rücknahmen chef
diese impfpflicht eigentlich noch
zwingend denn selbst in gepostete
pflegerinnen und pfleger sich infizieren
können und das virus auch weitergeben
können kann man dann noch für eine
schlecht argumentieren
also man muss ja immer zwei dinge
auseinanderhalten die impfung schützt
auf der einen seite denjenigen der
geimpft ist vor schwerer erkrankung und
natürlich wenn man jetzt über infiziert
wird ist das ein ein wert in sich
und es ist auch so dass einige monate
nach der impfung durchaus ein schutz
besteht denn er nimmt nur leider relativ
bald ab worüber man diskutieren sollte
aber die daten sind
die auf dem tisch wenn wir jetzt bald
omikron angepasste impfstoffe haben
sollen wird die verwenden oder sollen
wir die alten impfstoffe noch nehmen
oder wer kriegt die neuen impfstoffe
würden dann zum beispiel gerade die
pflege und das krankenhauspersonal
priorisiert oder natürlich auch gruppen
die besonders wohlrabe sind das sind so
sachen die ich eigentlich gerne mal
diskutieren würde und ich stimme schon
zu es wird viel besser gewesen werden
diese impfpflicht früher gehabt und noch
besser auch da bin ich vollkommen
d'accord wenn wir diese impfung
freiwillig erfolgt wäre auch von
pflegern und angehörigen der der
medizinischen berufe und ich finde schon
dass diese menschen die ja mit sehr viel
kranken und und und schwierig zu
behandeln menschen in berührung kommen
dass die auch eine verpflichtung haben
die zu schützen wo immer es geht und
natürlich wird man sich fragen müssen
wenn jetzt einmal geimpft ist zweimal
geimpft ist wann muss man die dritte
impfung erfolgen von dem personal das
sind sicherlich alle frauen ich kenne
diese 17 seiten der eben gesprochen
worden es ist
schon drin steht entsprechend und ob man
sich daran eben auch orientieren kann
daten zu den krankenkassen impfstoffen
werden wir frühestens im märz haben nach
meiner schätzung
das ist alles richtig und wir haben
varianten viren entwickeln sich so und
jetzt haben wir das die situation dass
man sagt jetzt muss man den impfstoff
anpassen an eine neue variante dann
werden neue varianten kommen da muss man
den impfstoff wieder anpassen das klingt
alles ganz vertraut nach einer
grippeschutzimpfung
dann hab ich nämlich vier varianten die
extra impfen wenn ich jetzt sage und drk
zahlen sind da sehr schwammig die habe
ich damals auch kritisiert kriegt sie
sich immer noch die access mortalität
aber es gibt sein wo gesagt wird in
deutschland bei einer schweren grippe
grippewelle sterben 25.000 menschen dann
kann ich doch nicht mal angenommen
omikron wie viele sterben dann
vielleicht dann unicom nächstes 5.000
10.000 seien aber in der grippe
potenziell 25.000 da keiner sagen ich
möchte eine omikron impfpflicht
dezidiert omikron und grippe nicht das
macht einfach keinen sinn unter verliere
ich den bürgerinnen und die bürgerin
weil die absagen ist es gibt ja andere
dinge die auch gefährlich sind und
dieses das pandemie geschehen dass wir
überwältigt waren da sind sich glaube
ich alle einig dass das durch ist die
krankenhäuser laufen nicht mehr über was
keiner vor dem krankenhaus warten bis er
behandelt wird und wir kommen langsam
mit dieser micon variante in sphären die
sehr nahe an anderen viren sind wie zb
dem grippevirus und dem vergleich vor
zwei jahren habe ich einen moment
abgelegt abgelehnt aber die montanes
raten sind jetzt mittlerweile in gut da
sind die argumente herbei gleich also
erstens wir kommen ohnehin zu spät es
wäre leben zu retten gewesen wenn wir
das vor wenigstens einem jahr mit dem
impfstoff schon eingeführt hätten und
zweitens es gibt jetzt sogar gute
argumente dagegen ich fange mal mit dem
ersten im nachhinein ist da was dran
glaube ich wir haben uns wahrscheinlich
zu lange vor gemacht und waren überzeugt
davon es muss uns doch gelingen im
grunde genommen die ganze gesellschaft
dann zu überzeugen sich impfen zu lassen
und wir stellen fest das war leider eine
falsche kalkulation nur wie bei vielen
anderen in der pandemie weiß man es
vorher nicht und umgekehrt muss man auch
sagen dann hat man war damals noch in
der opposition
vor der zeit eine impfpflicht
einzuführen bevor er nicht wirklich
alles ausgereizt worden ist um eine hohe
impfquoten auf freiwilliger basis
erreichen das wäre auch nicht ganz
leicht geworden was die vermittelbarkeit
angeht jetzt sind wir in einer situation
wo wir die impfpflicht nicht mehr glaube
ich realistischerweise gegen die omikron
werde brauchen nachdem nach der wicklung
die wir erwarten sollten nächste woche
hoffentlich vielleicht noch diese woche
der scheitelpunkt erreicht sein und gibt
es natur dann sollte es auch wieder
runter gehen wenn es wieder wärmer wird
aber was ich höre ich bin ja selber kein
wissenschaftler ist die chance für die
herbst und winkel herbst und im winter
geht es wieder los dann gibt es eine
weit überwiegende wahrscheinlichkeit für
eine neue welle und wir wissen auch
nicht was der gegner sein wird ich habe
gelernt dass man in den fachkreisen von
schmusekatzen und tigern redet was von
beiden ist dann wohl sein könnte also ob
es eine gefährliche sehr ansteckende
variante ist oder eine die uns eher noch
hilfen im grunde war wilden verlor es
ist die gängige argumentation und dafür
wollen wir uns schützen und wollen nie
wieder ins lesen für mich ist eigentlich
das entscheiden wir haben jetzt zwei
jahre diese pandemien den knochen und
grüne sind wir alle möhre davon und ich
finde wir müssen jetzt den ausweg nehmen
aus der pandemie ich mag mir nicht
vorstellen dass wir einen dritten winter
erleben so wie ihn jetzt haben so und
damit dann sind wir bei einer reihe von
fragen nämlich der wie wir jetzt bei
dieser situation zur einrichtung
bezogenen empfehle ich die allgemeine
noch durchsetzen wollen und wie kann man
gut argumentieren dagegen dass sie aus
der sicht des einen oder anderen in
diesem land eigentlich schon zu spät
kommt also die frage ob sie zu früh oder
zu spät kommt hat ja für die jetzt
anstehende
entscheidungen keine bedeutung sondern
die frage ist es jetzt ein instrument
das auch beispielsweise der
fertigung im angesicht der verfassung
standhält und das ist eher eine frage
mit vielen komplexen abwägung ethische
abwägung deshalb haben wir das ja in die
hand des parlaments gegeben einige djs
wie dass die älteren waren und sind zu
schützen der karton freuen dann müssen
wir nochmal klären worüber wir genau
reden denn die allgemeine impfpflicht
ist das eine die einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht ist das andere ja das
argument aufnehmen wenn sie jetzt sehen
wie sehr wir uns über die einrichtungs
bezogene schon streiten glauben sie dann
eigentlich noch an die allgemeine hat
das problem ist dass wir im moment wenn
wir uns anschauen wie omikron sich
verhält ist natürlich die begründung für
viele maßnahmen möglicherweise entfällt
das hat ja auch eher weil gesagt die
daten die wir jetzt haben zur belegung
auf den intensivstationen auch auf die
normalstation
lassen es vermuten dass wir durch diese
welle
ordentlich durchkommen dass wir keine
überlastung sehen und würde es bei
dieser omikron variante bleiben spricht
viel dafür dass haben wir ja auch gerade
vom mediziner gehört dass das viele der
schweren maßnahmen nicht mehr
rechtfertigt die wir in der
vergangenheit genutzt haben und jetzt
ist die frage haben
wir ausreichend fakten um sagen zu
können da wird möglicherweise irgendeine
variante auftauchen die könnte hässlich
sein die uns berechtigt menschen dazu zu
bringen sich auch gegen ihren willen
impfen zu lassen also es wird keine
zwangsimpfungen geben das ist in
deutschland ausgeschlossen da kommt kein
polizist unter keinen umständen aber wo
wir den menschen eine solche pflicht
auferlegen und ich persönlich meine dass
wir bevor wir darüber reden auch noch
mal stärker aber die frage reden müssen
reicht nicht auch eine altersbezogene im
pflicht denn wir sehen an den zahlen
dass auch omikron die jetzigen varianten
auch wieder stärker die älteren
schädigen und worüber wir auch sprechen
müssen ist ob wir nicht mit dem einsatz
moderner antiviraler medikamente hier
auch uns gut wenn wir gleich verrückt
sein geschäft noch mal fragen weil auch
das ist eigentlich ein rationales
argument ab schon dagegen wenn wir eine
behandelbare krankheit haben muss man
nicht mehr über eine impfpflicht reden
aber jetzt macht und ich will nur eins
sagen damit das jetzt nicht zu simpel
zugespitzt wird diese medikamente sind
im labor extrem erfolgreich wir müssen
natürlich jetzt mit den kliniken gleich
frau rückseite den klinikern wir müssen
nur jetzt mit der richtlinie entsprechen
ob wir die weil die sehr früh angewandt
werden müssen ob wir die ausreichend
schnell an die patienten an die
betroffenen sie sind weiter für über 50
das ist interessant dass sie sagen wenn
impfpflicht dann ist ihr modell ein
alters bezogen das habe ich nicht nee
das habe ich nicht gesagt das wird immer
wieder verkürzt sondern wir müssen wenn
wir diese maßnahme an der verfassung
messen müssen wir immer prüfen gibt es
mildere mittel als dieses und die
altersbezogene ist milder als die
allgemeine und der einsatz antiviraler
medikamente ist er werde daraus mittel
dann haben wir es jetzt also ja es kann
und jetzt sind wir aber ganz erstaunt
weil sie müssen ja noch mit fahrverbot
man diese einrichtung bezogene
impfpflicht verteidigen denn die ist
beschlossen und die ist gesetz und das
haben sie gerade für argumentiert was
machen wir denn jetzt mit dem
ungeimpften pfleger wird der jetzt also
entlassen wenn auch das gesundheitsamt
nicht in der lage dazu ist diese
gespräche mit ihm zu führen bekommt er
einen lohnausgleich oder bekommt er
nicht werden die arbeitslos oder nicht
das ist die eingangs ursprungs frage von
herrn hologic
das fest wir haben zu einem zeitpunkt
als wir den schutz vor adler
gruppenstärken wollten und man muss
immer wieder darauf hinweisen haben die
meisten menschen in den altenheimen
verloren wir hatten monate in einzelnen
bundesländern wo 90 prozent der toten
aus den alten und pflegeeinrichtungen
kam bei schlimm
als ampel gesagt wir müssen diese
menschen stärker schützen als die
vorgängerregierung getan hat wir haben
das in einem ersten schritt mit einer
testpflicht und dann kam aus bayern
insbesondere besonders laut der wunsch
aber auch von anderen wir müssen über
diese testpflicht hinausgehen wir
brauchen auch die impfpflicht für das
pflegerische personal dort und weil es
in der tat wir haben es verhängen gehört
für
berufe die besonders viel mit variablen
gruppen zu hören auch eine besondere
garantenpflicht gab gab es dann im
dezember eben die mehrheit dafür dass
wir das in ein gesetz gießen mich ja ist
es
jetzt ist es so das gesetz ist völlig
klar ab dem 15 märz müssen menschen die
diese berufe die übrigens auch sehr
präzise im gesetz aufgeführt sind die
menschen die einrichtungen die das
betrifft die menschen die dort arbeiten
müssen ihrem arbeitgeber einen
impfnachweis erbringen oder dass sie
sich eben nicht impfen lassen können
oder dass sie genesen sind der
arbeitgeber hat meldet das landratsamt
hat das zu überprüfen ob es sich
möglicherweise um fälschungen handelt
und so weiter und übergibt dann
wenn er der meinung über gibt dann den
datensatz dem gesundheitsamt und wenn
dieser pflicht nicht nachgekommen wird
hat das gesundheitsamt die möglichkeit
dann maßnahmen zu ergreifen
nämlich beispielsweise dann einen
bescheid zu erlassen dass diese menschen
diesen beruf nicht mehr ausüben dürfen
weil sie sich ihrer berufsbezogenen
pflicht dort widersetzen und daran kann
natürlich die folge auch geknüpft sein
dass ich dann dem beruf in der
einrichtung nicht mehr ausüben darf und
das kann unter umständen auch dazu
führen dass das arbeitsverhältnis
beendet werden kann
da einmal ganz kurz was sagen also aus
meiner zeit in der notaufnahme da habe
ich ja mit der pflege ärztliche pflege
werden waren alle auf augenhöhe
und wenn sie sagen fünf prozent sind
nicht geimpft in bayern sind es wohl 10
15 prozent fragt dann auch mal jemand
die pflege weil das ist schon ein
riesenunterschied die arbeiten so am
limit da macht es schon ein unterschied
ob 100 leute in die schichten eingeteilt
werden können oder nur 95 oder geben
gegebenenfalls 85 und die pflegerinnen
und pfleger die ich kenne geimpft die
sagen du wir sind so am limit und es hat
noch bis er sich noch keiner wirklich
erkenntlich gezeigt und so richtig
gehört doch nicht wenn jetzt uns nochmal
zehn leute wegbrechen dann ist es also
da hat einer gesagt plane gesagt ist es
dann egal ob geimpft oder nicht geimpft
oder ob wir sie nicht versorgen können
dann wird auch leid geschehen und das
ist das ist für mich natürlich möchte
ich direkt rolle ein das ist ein ganz
wichtiger punkt und ich möchte mal sagen
das war meine partei die bis zum schluss
immer wieder diese frage gestellt hat
insbesondere an die ostdeutschen
bundesländer und die süddeutschen
bundesländer wo wir die größte skepsis
im pflegerischen personals seid ihr euch
wirklich sicher dass ihr das wollt und
seid ihr euch auch wirklich sicher dass
dadurch nicht ein neuer stamm es steht
personal einen tritt diese frage haben
wir sehr laut und sehr klar und sehr
präzise gestellt und die antwort
insbesondere der östlichen und auch der
südliche bundesländer war die haben
dieses problem im griff oder wir glauben
nicht daran dass es so groß wie es
vermutet wird dass jetzt nicht geht ist
nachdem wir diese frage gestellt haben
sie uns von den bundesländern so
beantwortet wurde das jetzt wo man merkt
dass die eigene einschätzung
möglicherweise falsch war man versucht
dem bund einen schwarzen peter
zuzuschieben ich hätte halt einzelne
bundes ich einzelne bundesländer ich
will doch folgendes sagen und wenn es so
ist dass das jetzt die folge ist und
deshalb der wunsch ist diese maßnahme
aufzuheben dann kann man darüber reden
aber das ist ja nicht das was er rolle
check oder sagen neuen check und herr
söder sagen es sei ein so schlechtes
gesetz gemacht worden dass man damit
nichts anfangen das finde ich ist ein
stückweit unehrlich wenn das was sie
sagen der beweggrund ist dann finde ich
muss man darüber nüchtern und
pragmatisch sprechen können aber man
soll nicht versuchen anderen schwarzen
peter zuzuschieben weil man sich selber
möglicherweise wird das wäre unehrlich
so und dann sind wir dabei das nicht nur
herr hologic und herr söder dieses
gesetz kritisieren sondern auch aus
deutsche kollegen und übrigens auch
gewerkschaften und sozialverbände her
weil also da wird schon gesagt das ist
mit der heißen nadel gestrickt und wir
brauchen hinweise wir wollen eigentlich
auch richtlinien des bundes haben denken
sie dass es dazu kommt oder glauben sie
dass es am ende eben wie auch tot
geredet werden wird also ich bin ich bin
sicher dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister dass karl
lauterbach etwas vorlegen wird ich hoffe
sehr dass damit alle seiten der
bundesländer konstruktiv umgegangen wird
man kann alles zu reden und man kann
überall die haare so besuchen das ist
völlig klar aber wenn wir jetzt
gemeinsam das ziel haben einen
gemeinsamen beschlossenes gesetz gut
rüberzubringen dann scheint ich habe mir
dafür eine sehr sehr gute möglichkeit
und ich muss ehrlich sagen ich sehe
natürlich sehr unterschiedliche
impfquoten in den einzelnen
bundesländern dann gibt es große
unterschiede
es gibt schon finde ich ein problem zu
sagen na ja da wo die impfquote
besonders niedrig ist da muss eine
impfpflicht besonders lange
hinausgezögert werden ich verstehe schon
im praktischen hintergrund dessen aber
wenn ich mal vom schutz der menschen
denke er denke dieses jahr geht und
deren schutz uns besonders am herzen
liegt muss dann ist das schon ein
problem aber bei guten will werden wir
zueinander kommen nur der gute wille
muss überall vorhanden sein herr hologic
nochmal befürchten sie denn den notstand
in einzelnen heimen in einzigen
einzelnen pflegeeinrichtung und müsse
dann die bundeswehr kommt
also wir reden ja nicht nur über pflege
wir reden über hebammen über andere
berufe über arztpraxen wir müssen
natürlich das thema
versorgungssicherheit im blick haben und
das müssen wir überall im blick haben
und der bundesjustizminister ist jetzt
in fragen auch ein bisschen ausgewichen
was passiert dann mit kündigung
lohnfortzahlung die gewerkschaft hat
sich der auch normal dezidiert geäußert
der deutsche pflegerat heute deswegen
werbe ich ja dafür dass man das was wir
gesagt haben ernst nimmt und dafür
lösungen sucht damit wir das gemeinsam
gut hinkriegen und ich will noch mal
eins sagen man hat der branche gesagt
die einrichtungs bezogene ihm pflegt ist
der erste schritt und die allgemeine
wird folgen da fehlt im moment ist
vertrauen und wenn ich sehe dass der
bundestag nächste woche nicht diskutiert
das wieder verschiebt dann kann ich das
auch verstehen das bringt tatsächlich
keine glaubwürdigkeit auch in richtung
der medizinischen und pflegerischen
berufe das stimmt das haben die pfleger
sich hier auch in unserer sendung
gewünscht und die pflegerinnen da könnte
man jetzt auch sagen okay also am ende
wenn dann die impfpflicht nicht kommt ja
dann war sie auch nicht dann wird sich
herr aiwanger wahrscheinlich noch ärgern
dass er sich nun noch impfen lassen
musste oder
war das eine frage an mich ja eine
ernsthafte na ja ich wollte sich zum
schmunzeln bringen ich gesagt also die
frage ist denken sie also hier ist die
angst gemeinte frage sie sagen jetzt
dass die allgemeine impfpflicht damit in
noch weitere ferne rutscht das
befürchten sie und ist das der
eigentliche grund oder ist der
eigentliche grund des die union
eigentlich diese impfpflicht nicht mehr
will herr wilczek auch das nicht wir
stehen zu der einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht wir wollen bloß dass sie
vernünftig umgesetzt und vollzogen
werden kann das haben wir gesagt wenn
der bundesgesundheitsminister jetzt
dieses thema aufgreift und wenn wir
lösungen kriegen weder ministerpräsident
es angedeutet hat dann werden wir uns
doch denen nicht verschließen aber dann
haben wir doch noch mal in der
diskussion erreicht dass es besser wird
und dass wir dann gemeinsam wissen wo
der weg hingeht aber ich möchte schon
auch dass die allgemeine impfpflicht
jetzt auch zeitnah kommt dass es dazu
vorlagen gibt und dass wir das dann auch
angehen also was wir erreicht haben ist
erstmal millionenfaches kopfschütteln in
der ganzen bevölkerung weil ein gesetz
das von das fast einstimmig beschlossen
wurde auf einmal in frage gestellt wird
und die fragen die sich stellen die kann
man tatsächlich auch da vernünftig
miteinander klären in der gesundheit
gesundheitsminister konferenz mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister zusammen da
gibt es überall das gemeinsame interesse
also ich bin ja froh drüber rolle chat
wenn sie sagen da diese episode die wir
jetzt erlebt haben die gehört der
vergangenheit an ich wollte wirklich das
wäre so denn der schaden der angerichtet
worden ist erst recht nicht das sehe ich
nicht so ich glaube dass der schaden
viel größer ist wenn man ein gesetz
vollzieht es eben nicht vollzogen werden
kann und ich will ihnen deutlich sagen
gesetze die im november beschlossen
wurden unter omikron bedingungen heute
muss man das noch mal anders sehen und
wir müssen auch mal den mut haben wenn
ein gesetz nicht funktioniert das zu
sagen und dann auch zu verbessern
möchten sie es verbessern oder finden
sie dass es jetzt eigentlich eine neue
situation gibt holczer ich habe es immer
noch nicht verstanden wir stehen zur
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht aber
die umsetzung und der vollzug ist nicht
so wie er sein sollte deswegen muss man
umsetzungs zeiten haben und nichts
anderes haben wir gesagt wir sind bei
der zweiten großen frage nämlich der was
sich in diesem land ändern sollte an all
den maßnahmen
wir in deutschland haben und da man die
politik zur geduld und viele haben die
schon nicht mehr
brechen jetzt keine exit-strategie
debatte vom zaun das wäre völlig
unangemessen ein völlig falsches signal
die debatte ist längst da
frühlingsgefühle mitten im winter
überall in deutschland öffnen die blüten
fast täglich kippen landesfürsten chor
ohne einschränkungen zweig beim shoppen
ist de facto abgeschafft
[Musik]
großveranstaltungen mit tausenden
besuchern sind wieder möglich
verheißungsvolle botschaften vor dem
bund länder treffen am mittwoch wir
sollten uns vorbereiten die
grundrechtseingriffe stück für stück
zurück zu nehmen da wir im moment eine
stabile situation in den krankenhäusern
haben es ist glaube ich der richtige
zeitpunkt über lockerungen zu
diskutieren
[Musik]
der druck steigt denn reihum erklären
europäische länder die pandemie für
beendet
in dänemark werden alle maßnahmen
einkassiert von der maske bis zum ins
nachweis und das bei einer fünftausender
inzidenz
unvorstellbar für den obersten deutschen
corona bekämpfer der stemmt sich gegen
die wucht einer anrollenden öffnungs
welle und steht ziemlich allein da wir
können also breite lockerungen wie sie
derzeit diskutiert werden zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt nicht vertreten nicht wundere
mich über die diskussion die zum teil in
der politik jetzt zu beobachten ist
bodman und damit sind wir bei dem was
dieses land sich jetzt an öffnungs
diskussionen oder öffnungs diskussions
orgien sollte würde frau merkel
vielleicht gesagt haben im oktober sind
sie noch heftig kritisiert worden für
das auslaufen der epidemischen notlage
wie die die fdp damals sehr plädiert hat
jetzt sagt der fraktionsvorsitzende der
fdp zum neunzehnten dritten laufen die
maßnahmen die frischen maßnahmen der
ampel regierung aus und wir brauchen
keine mehr was sagt der
bundesjustizminister brauchen wir gar
keine maßnahmen mehr sind ihr dänemark
also zunächst einmal der hinweis auf die
rechtslage ist ja richtig das ist auch
notwendig weil es ja auch
ministerpräsident wie ein kretschmann
gibt die ja so eine art tabuisierung
strategie versucht haben zu
implementieren das wir ist ostern
darüber reden dürfen ostern ist zu spät
wir müssen im märz und wir müssen auch
bei der jetzt anstehenden mpk am besten
über einen fahrplan sprechen was vor dem
hintergrund der jetzigen situation
möglich ist und da ist eine ganze menge
möglich meine ich also die 2g regelungen
sind ja in einigen bundesländern auch
schon durch gerichte gekippt worden wenn
man sich die hospitalisierung raten die
infektionsraten anschaut kann man jetzt
nicht sagen dass niedersachsen
schlechter dasteht im gegenteil da gibt
es andere länder die mit den maßnahmen
sogar schlechter dastehen das heißt es
ist verantwortbar das zu machen es gibt
auch andere schritte die man ergreifen
kann und dann ist ein grundsatz wichtig
und den dürfen wir nicht vergessen weil
wir uns glaube ich schon ein bisschen zu
sehr an bestimmte dinge gewohnt haben
aber nicht die freiheit muss sich
begründen dass bürger ihre freiheit
ausüben sondern ich muss jeden eingriff
in freiheit und grundrechte begründen
und das
prinzip mit der wir diese eingriffe in
den letzten zwei jahren begründet haben
war immer dass wir
einen zusammenbruch unseres
gesundheitssystems abwehren wollten wenn
wir jetzt aber sehen dass wir stabile
verhältnisse auf den intensivstationen
haben dass wir beherrschbare
verhältnisse auch auf die normalstation
haben
und wir dann
in zukunft auch ein deutlich abnehmen
des infektionsgeschehen haben was ihr
alle modelle prognostizieren dass wir
jetzt schon in der nähe eine
scheitelpunkte sind also danach die lage
sich weiter entspannen wird dann ist es
ein gebot der rechtsstaatlichkeit dass
wenn die begründenden tatsachen oder die
gefahr vor der man sich schützen will
wenn diese gefahrensituation abnimmt
dann müssen auch die eingriffe in die
grundrechte zurückgefahren sorgen jetzt
haben sie eine ganz lange antwort
gegeben ich erinnere sie noch mal an
meine frage neunzehnter dritter werden
zum zwanzigsten dritter des jahres 2022
alle maßnahmen auslaufen das haben sie
mal versprochen
also die das ist die rechtslage wenn wir
das nicht verlängern wird das genauso
passieren und die frage ist jetzt das
wird man ja politik diskutieren ob es
gründe gibt das zu verlängern und wenn
es so sein sollte dass die zahlen sich
so entwickeln wie das ja auch die
modelle vorsehen gibt es viele gute
gründe zu sagen vielleicht brauchen wir
keine maßnahmen mehr vielleicht da
vielleicht reicht auch die ffb zwei
maske das ist genau die sind hier ja
frau immer wenn wir nicht darüber
diskutieren dann ist die folge ganz
sicher aber dass die zahlen wird laufen
die maßnahmen aus und ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir möglichst wenige
maßnahmen vielleicht sogar gar keine
mehr brauchen wenn nämlich die
infektionszahlen so in den keller gehen
wie das auch die modelle vorhersehen und
wer auf stabile situation in den
krankenhäusern wir fragen nach
düsseldorf rübsamen chef des virus ist
an
zählt kann man dann auch davon ausgehen
dass das virus schon chaos also ich sehe
das überhaupt nicht so dass das virus
angezählt ist man darf auch wenn man
sagt alles harmlos alles gut alles
stabil nicht vergessen dass wir in
deutschland jetzt da sind wo dänemark
mitte dezember war also man kann dass
die situation in den ländern nicht
vergleichen und man darf nicht vergessen
dass wir 100 200 tote pro tag nach wie
vor haben und wir sind jetzt erst am
scheitelpunkt der welle also das wird
noch eine zeit lang weitergehen und
insofern ist jeder einzelne der aufgrund
von nicht weitergeführten
schutzmaßnahmen sich zusätzlich
infiziert und zusätzlich stirbt in
meinen augen ein mensch zu viel denn tod
ist nun mal um unumkehrbar ich kann
maßnahmen sollten kann ich wieder zum
leben erwecken also ich denke das ist
alles sehr sehr leichtsinnig gedacht im
moment hinzu kommt dass wenn das virus
sich in so vielen menschen vermehren
kann wir hatten jetzt weltweit pro tag 4
millionen neuinfektionen mit dem virus
dann ist zu erwarten dass sich weitere
varianten bilden und wir haben keine
ahnung wie die aussehen werden das kann
man nicht voraussagen das wird sich
zeigen müssen und insofern glaube ich
den menschen jetzt wieder zu sagen ihr
könnt bald die große freiheit zurück
haben ist genau so verkehrt wie es am
anfang war zu sagen und wenn der
impfstoff erst mal da ist kriegt jeder
die impfung und dann ist das virus
wechsel war ja mal die idee dass man das
damit reduzieren könnte haben inzwischen
gelernt das virus ändert sich der die
geimpften lassen nach in ihrer reaktion
und sind nicht mehr so gut geschützt vor
der infektion gott sei dank sind sie
noch sehr gut geschützt vor krankheit
und das ist für mich natürlich ein ganz
wesentlicher grund weiter zu impfen aber
ich möchte sehr davor waren die
situation ist zu unterschätzen dann sind
wir bei den beiden landespolitikern
derweil karl lauterbach warnt vor 400
und 500 toten am tag wenn wir jetzt
öffnen würden und es machen würden wie
israel sagen sie es ist richtig davor zu
warnen und ob noch obacht zu haben oder
sagen sie wir tun jetzt eigentlich gut
daran den menschen diese freiheit
zurückzugeben zweig ist der anfang sie
haben fußball ist noch zu nennen im
vergleich zu den bayern noch eine 500
schauer regelung bei sich in den stadien
das müssen wir jetzt auch langsam mal
lockern
also ganz klare frage sagen sie ich bin
team vorsicht oder sagen sie ich bin
team augenmaß ja ich bin im team
vorsichtig bin auch immer im team
geblieben er aber team vorsieht ist was
anderes als team panik weil ich habe in
letzter zeit eine menge mich mit
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern unterhalten die meisten
sagen ja man lernt immer dazu die
meisten sagen wir dürften jetzt bei den
scheitelpunkt erreicht haben und dann
sollte ist auch untergehen nicht
schlagartig leider aber stück für stück
dann kommt auch eine wärmere jahreszeit
sie sagen nein wir können bald schon
davon ausgehen dass wir einen
entspannten frühling einen entspannten
sommer haben und sie warnen vor dem
herbst so und nach zwei jahren krisen
management und nur unterbrochen habe ich
eines gelernt erster sagt niemals nie in
der pandemie und
zweitens sie werden verstehen dass wir
gerne für den fall eines falles ein
instrumentarium hatten dass wir dann
auch tatsächlich anwenden können niemand
muss die säure haben dass das
überflüssige weise angewandt wird es
gibt in deutschland eine sehr kritische
rechtsprechung die gerade in der
pandemie gezeigt hat dass ich habe da
meine erfahrung gemacht aber naja ich ja
schon vorher über die kommen
nicht rein das ist nicht das nicht der
punkt aber sie werden verstehen warum
diese instrumental als solches wichtig
ist so buschmann hat recht wir müssen
reden ich weiß was man noch machen dass
vielleicht in dem bewusstsein dass
keiner der beteiligten hier sozusagen
jetzt mit kanonen auf spatzen schießen
will wir haben auch alle eine kritische
öffentlichkeit zu hause wird es ja genau
der punkt weil die frage ist ja wollen
wir dieses virus
auslöschen das schaffen ja gar nicht so
volvo bis wohin wollen wir die zahlen
runter bringen wenn wir klar kann ich
kann immer ein horrorszenario malen und
sagen dann sterben 500 1000 leute aber
welcher zahl würden wir dann aufhören
die null erreichen wir niemals es gibt
genug andere infektionskrankheiten die
der sterben auch viele menschen dran wir
haben es ist ein bisschen ein weiter
herunter vergleich aber wir haben 300
40.000 tote jedes jahr aufgrund von herz
kreislauf versagen wovon die meisten
verhinderbar werden durch diverse
sozusagen lebens sozusagen in einem
maßnahmen lebens die andern massnahmen
also dass man muss jetzt mal bisschen im
verhältnis bleiben und sagen wir können
jetzt nicht einfach argumente
austauschen dass das gehen die leute
doch zu hause auch nicht mehr mit jeder
hat mit angepackt der locker und wurde
durch gezogen das vertrauen war groß
dann wurde die gefahr weniger dann hat
man schon gemerkt wie in der politik
gekoppelt wurde dann hat man jetzt
gemerkt dass er auf einmal der genesenen
status draußen drei monate sind im
bundestag wurde heute erst beschlossen
dass die sechs monate aufgehoben werden
weil scheinbar die arbeit für die
menschen dort wichtiger ist als für den
selbständigen draußen dass wir verlieren
das vertrauen bei den menschen weil auch
komisch argumentiert wird und frau
rübsamen schiff kann er vielleicht auch
noch mal ich bin kein biologe aber noch
mal durchführen die meisten coronaviren
die sind heute ein banaler schnupfen das
heißt die waren mal sehr sehr gefährlich
und ein virus wenn es sich durchsetzt
dass omikron hat sich durchgesetzt weil
es die lücke gefunden hatte sind aber
millionen varianten geben tag dabei
zugucken wie kann mich durchsetzen das
hat die lücke gefunden setzt sich durch
ein virus hat gar nichts davon
unglaublich tödlich zu sein der welt
sterben das ist idealerweise entwickelt
sich dieses virus und ein schnupfen und
dann ist es ein schnupfen wie damals
auch die anderen vorläufers es gibt so
viele follower aber da müssen wir frauen
zusammen sprang der punkt es ist werden
argumente ausgetauscht und da verliert
man irgendwann die leute zu hause dass
sie sagen ich habe also ehrlich gesagt
ich kann verstehen wenn leute sagen ich
hab dich noch zu früh so wir sind dem
ruf seinem chef dass schönheit noch
durch sie müssen sie sind das schon mal
durchgegangen und haben darüber
gesprochen dass es vier coronaviren
schon mal zuvor gab die sind alle
natürlich heute normale erkältungsviren
irgendwie sagen die pandemie historiker
auch dass am ende jede mutation immer
ungefährlicher ist als das ursprungs
also ist die ursprungs variante wie groß
dann noch mal die frage wie sehr können
wir darauf bauen dass sich dieses corona
virus verhält wie jedes andere wie jedes
andere pandemische virus bisher in der
menschheitsgeschichte also das ist sind
immer anpassungsprozesse den nicht nur
vonseiten des virus passieren sondern
auch von seiten des wirts wenn genügend
menschen oft du noch kontakt gemacht
haben mit dem virus und nicht mehr so
empfänglich sind und auch nicht mehr so
leicht krank werden dann wird sich
dieses krankheitsgeschehen natürlich
verbessern aber so weit sind wir noch
nicht wie gesagt wir haben noch die
vielen toten und das sind natürlich
überwiegend ungeimpfte mensch aber die
sagen uns doch omikron ist nicht harmlos
ja es ist kommt nicht mehr an so viele
leute ran weil viele geimpft sind aber
an die an die es ankommt gerade wenn die
etwas älter sind aber auch einige junge
dabei dann ist es nach wie vor tödlich
wenn man pech hat und deswegen halte ich
diesen augenblick der diskussion
zusammen das ist schon so wie die grippe
wir haben 120 tausend corona tote
grippetote pro jahr sechs bis 10.000 das
sieht man auch schon eine größenordnung
dazwischen ja ich halte diesen zeitpunkt
einfach für verfrüht wir wissen es nicht
und was ich aber noch mal gerne
aufnehmen möchte was wir dringend tun
sollten um es auf den nächsten herbst
vorzubereiten ist die impfstelle die
medikamente die jetzt erstmalig zur
verfügung stehen die man als tabletten
früh im infektionsgeschehen schlucken
kann die das virus unterdrücken das ist
in klinische studien bereits bewiesen
worden um 30 sogar 90 prozent wird man
dadurch vor krankheit oder sogar tod
geschützt dass wir die so schnell wie
möglich lernen in den kliniken in den
arztpraxen einzusetzen und gucken was
können wir denn damit ausrichten und ich
könnte mir vorstellen wenn wir viele
fälle die sich dann noch anstecken damit
gut behandeln können und uns schützen
können dann hat plötzlich das corona
wieder ein ganz anderes gesicht aber es
ich sage nicht es ist schon harmlos auf
keinen fall genau das steht noch das er
gibt es klinische studien bisher es ist
noch nachzuweisen dass sie tatsächlich
diese medikamente schon ihre begründete
wirkung haben herr holly check in
münchen muss uns helfen weil genau wird
der beantwortung dieser frage herr
hologic es gibt heute gemessen 2 138
tote in deutschland es gab an den
anderen tagen zuvor 280 das waren in
anderen zeiten auch in münchen auch in
bayern in anführungsstrichen zahlen die
ausgereicht haben harte maßnahmen zu
begründen was hat sich denn jetzt an
dieser situation eigentlich gerne
also erstmal ist natürlich jeder tote
einer zuviel das ist unbestritten aber
tatsächlich 'so mikron nicht älter und
wenn wir unser gesundheitssystem als
maßstab nehmen und die belastung oder
dass wir es nicht überlasten wollen dann
haben wir jetzt eine andere lage und wir
müssen lageangepasst entscheiden und
deswegen haben wir gott sei dank jetzt
auf den intensivstationen in bayern nur
noch ein drittel des umstandes dass wir
bei delta hatten und auf den normalen
stationen zwar einen zuwachs aber es ist
beherrschbar solange auch das
pflegepersonal da ist als er die sorge
dass in der kritischen infrastruktur
durch quarantäne und isolation wieder
etwas passieren kann aber wenn es
beherrschbar ist dann stimme ich zu dass
wir auch die freiheit nicht mehr in dem
maße einschränken ich glaube wir werden
maßnahmen brauchen auch über den 19 märz
hinaus da stimme ich an weil zu weil wir
damit auch ein stück freiheit
garantieren wenn wir maßnahmen haben die
wir einsetzen können bei bedarf aber der
maßstab ist die belastung unseres
gesundheitssystems noch mal wie groß ist
ihre sorge sie lassen in die
fußballstadien ich habe es bei
niedersachsen erwähnt da sind es noch
500 die vereine klagen dagegen sie
lassen in bayern wieder 15.000 zuschauer
in die stadien
sie füllen jetzt also die
fußball-stadien wie groß ist ihre angst
dass sie auch wieder krankenhäuser
fällen also wir hatten ja sehr früh
schon sehr stringente maßnahmen weil wir
auch in delta schon sehr betroffen waren
und deswegen passen wir jetzt an der
lage wir werden aber auch weiter
aufpassen und einem sehr engen
monitoring genau auf die krankenhäuser
schauen wir müssen notfalls auch
bremsbereit sein aber wir hoffen dass es
natürlich jetzt in eine phase geht wo
ein stück weit mehr normalität möglich
ist und wir fragen uns natürlich auch
herr buschmann wenn wir diese kategorien
wechseln und sagen also bis gestern
haben wir noch auf die idee essen
geschaut und wollten dass die
intensivstationen nicht so überfüllt
sind wir wollten das gesundheitssystem
nicht überfordern dann wollten wir die
kritische infrastruktur schützen und
befürchteten personalnotstand der nicht
eingetreten ist jetzt rechnen wir uns
also aus welche zahl der toten wir haben
wie problematisch ist in ihren augen
dass die kategorien unserer entscheidung
gewechselt werden ja das ist
aus zwei gründen schwierig einmal weil
es vertrauen kostet weil die menschen
den eindruck haben man sucht
gewissermaßen nach einer begründung ich
weiß dass die beteiligten das nicht so
meinen aber dass der eindruck der
entsteht das kostet vertrauen das andere
ist natürlich auch die rechtliche
perspektive reden über
grundrechtseingriffe und es reicht nicht
aus wenn wir sagen es gibt ich sag's mal
ich juli das argument mal so es gibt
draußen unvernünftige menschen die
lassen sich nicht impfen und die landen
jetzt auf der intensivstation ist
deshalb müssen wir die ein bisschen vor
sich selber schützen das reicht auch
nicht aus das wäre paternalismus sondern
es reicht nur aus das ist auch in der
entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zur bundes
notbremse so beschrieben für es wir
brauchen diese begründung des überragend
wichtigen gemeinschafts gutes und das
ist der schutz der funktionstüchtigkeit
des gesundheitssystems selbst und wenn
die nicht wenn das gesundheitssystem
nicht gefährdet ist wenn wir den
menschen eine vernünftige versorgung
anbieten können dann haben wir keine
ausreichende brücke der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft gibt heute
entfernungen wir sind nicht überfordert
dass herr lauterbach übertreibt ja durch
man
den eindruck haben ja manche aber ich
will jetzt hier keine haltungsnoten
abgeben ich habe ihn ja hier klar meine
meinung gesagt und der
verfassungsrechtliche zusammenhang ist
klar es handelt sich um
grundrechtseingriffe wenn wir die nicht
ausreichend begründen können etwa weil
keine bedrohung mehr für das
gesundheitssystem besteht dann müssen
wir die maßnahmen schritt für schritt
abbauen und dass man dann darüber
sprechen kann wenn sich die lage
verändern sollte also wenn wir
möglicherweise im herbst eine andere
situation hat dass man da auch drauf
reagieren muss das ist klar wenn jetzt
die lage so ist dass das
gesundheitssystem stabil ist dass wir
das die versorgung nicht gefährdet ist
ein miniatur lassen weder in
niedersachsen noch in bayern gibt es
glaube ich probleme mit der müllabfuhr
oder ist die kritische inhalte
schulrätin neues gibt aber jetzt schon
nahverkehrsunternehmen die haben ihre
fahrpläne verändern müssen also ist
nicht ganz ohne aber natürlich sind wir
nicht in einer krisenhaften situation
jetzt und deswegen werden wir jetzt auch
in lockerungen gehen können vertretbarer
weise bevor ich nur warnen ist dass wir
innerlich damit das kapitel als abgabe
betracht mit dem fehler haben wir
eigentlich zwei mal hintereinander in
den vergangenen beiden jahren gemacht
und das sollte uns kennen haben schon
gesagt und das neue schon gesagt wenn
wir jetzt lockern das kann im winter
wieder anders aussehen das ist nicht
mehr zu helfen das sollen uns kein
drittes mal passieren und deswegen
müssen wir lageangepasst reagieren ich
bin auch dafür dass wir jetzt wenn diebe
chance dazu besteht lockern ich meine
keiner von uns der diese windregel macht
wünscht sich dass magna definitiv
einsteigt muss sich auf einen schönen
frühling auf einen schönen sommer aber
ich möchte vermeiden dass wir in einem
bitteren herbst reingehen weil wir
dürfen eben auch nicht präventiv
freiheiten einschränken wenn wir keine
gefahrensituation haben man kann
maßnahmen vorbereiten und das ist ja das
recherchieren was wir sagen dass wir
rauskommen aus diesem täglich im
improvisierten diskutieren sondern dass
wir uns jetzt kriterien zurechtlegen und
dass wir ob nachvollziehbare kriterien
definieren beispielsweise eben wie wir
dieses problem der möglichen überlastung
des gesundheitssystems
operationalisieren des hommes alles das
haben wir gemacht und jetzt sollten wir
uns daran auch orientieren und eben
nicht die argumentation wechseln nicht
da hören wir genau da gehört man gut hin
und sagt das war bis gestern noch das
kriterium und wenn wir das heute nicht
mehr haben müssen und wollen und werden
wir lockern und dänemark ist schon ein
paar mal gefallen hier heute und also
sind wir dankbar lykke friis bei uns zu
haben
politikwissenschaftlerin aus dänemark
ministerin war sie auch schon mal in
diesem schönen land hoch im norden
und interessante geschichten hört und
weiß man aus eben genau ihrem landfrau
fries sie öffnen bei einer 5 tausende
inzidenz trotz omikron warum trauen sich
dass die dänen
ja man denkt ja die dänen haben nicht
mehr alle tassen im schrank aber der
punkt ist ja hier das in dänemark es
gibt eine entkopplung wir haben zwar
höhere fallzahlen aber wenn meine
krankenhäuser anschaut da gehen die
zahlen also runter und vor allem wissen
wir ja auch von den studien dass
umgekommen nicht so gefährlich ist wie
geld und vor allem ist ja auch ganz
großer teil der dänischen bevölkerung
geimpft und vor allem auch die eltern
teil der bevölkerung insofern ist die
lage einfach anders in dänemark vor
allem auch bald in dänemark hört man den
begriff nicht denn ich andauern hier in
deutschland höhere nämlich von blindflug
dass man nicht weiß wo man ist sozusagen
weil man die daten nicht wir haben die
daten in denen das ist also auch ein
ganz großer unterschied die
digitalisierung ist sehr sehr wichtig im
kampf gegen korona ist genau das gleiche
in dänemark wenn man landwirt ist dann
schaut man ja auch die wette tage bevor
man ernten geht da braucht man es
politiker natürlich auch verlässliche
daten bevor man lockern kann so dass da
haben sie alles irgendwie gleich schon
mal sehr herrlich und beschrieben was
anders ist in ihrem land als in unserem
es ist natürlich ganz wichtig zu sagen
man muss nicht eine diktatur sein um
eine präzise datenbasis haben die dänen
wissen quasi in echtzeit ob ihre bürger
geimpft sind oder nicht geimpft sind das
ist schon mal ein großer vorzug aber
warum ist das vertrauen ihrer bürger in
die politik so groß sie müssen über eine
impfpflicht gar nicht nachdenken oder
nee das ist nicht ein thema das ist auch
nie ein thema gewesen weil ich meine von
anfang an war das vertrauen der
regierung groß es gab auch eine klare
kommunikation und nicht dieses hin und
her und team öffnung und vorsicht um so
weiter und so fort es gab ein team
dänemark das war wichtig aber es soll
auch klar es gibt auch in anderen großen
unterschied ich meine dänemark ist ein
einheitsstaat ich meine wir haben nicht
16 bundesländer keine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und so
weiter und so fort da ist natürlich
einfacher hat eine klare positiven eine
klare linie zu haben aber jetzt ist es
halt so wir haben diese entkopplung die
fallzahlen gehen zwar hoch aber wie
gesagt ich meine die krankenhäuser haben
nicht diese schwierigkeiten und deshalb
hat die regierung und auch das dänische
parlament gesagt dann können wir nicht
eine situation haben wo es nicht diese
akute bedrohung gibt zur bevölkerung
dass man sagt jetzt müssen die
beschränkung einfach weiterlaufen dann
würde es dann ein problem mit dem
vertrauen geben dann muss man einfach
dass ich meine die verantwortung auch
und die bürger dann zurückgeben weil es
gibt ja auch ich meine dass sie sich
kostenfrei wenn man einfach die die
beschränkungen dann einfach weiterlaufen
lässt ich meine die die schüler ich
meinen können kommen nicht zur schule
ich mal die operation werden verschoben
es waren restaurants geschlossen und
zubereitungs wort und vor allem auch die
grundrechte werden ja eingeschränkt und
freiheit ist ein hohes gut und deshalb
hat die dänische regierung gesagt oder
auch das parlament deshalb müssen wir
die verhandlungsdruck geben dann zur
bevölkerung und wenn sich die zahlen
wieder verändern sollten frau fries dann
ist es tatsächlich so dass die regierung
auch wieder ansehen will klar ja klar
das kommt natürlich auch mit den
varianten an dass das weiß man ja nie
dann würde man halt auch dann ich mal
wird bevölkerung sei okay das machen wir
dann mit weil wir jetzt sehen okay jetzt
gibt es keine große gefahr und dann
werden dann aus die verschiedene
beschränkungen zurückgefunden
eigenverantwortung ist groß geschrieben
in dänemark und es ist ein land das
tatsächlich zeit genau weiß wann sich
welcher bürger impfen lässt danke für
diesen einblick in unseren nördlichen
nachbarn und damit sind wir natürlich
bei dem schönen wort eigenverantwortung
her weil wir sind das eher aus der not
die inzidenz einsteigen auch bei uns
berlin ist so ein beispiel auch eine
dreitausender incidents in manchen
stadtbezirken sogar eine viertausender
die gesundheitsämter ihr reagieren
überhaupt nicht mehr geschweige denn
dass ich noch mal irgendjemand
erkundigen würde wie eigentlich der
zustand eines patienten ist also fällt
uns in deutschland das wort
eigenverantwortung erst ein wenn wir
nicht mehr in der lage sind unser system
der kontakt nach verfolgung und der
betreuung wirklich aufrecht zu erhalten
doch das weiß ich nicht ich hätte mir
gewünscht die eigenverantwortung bei uns
wäre so ausgeprägt dass es unverändert
auch im letzten sommer gleich ein run
gegeben hätte wir wollen als alle impfen
lassen wenn wir heute eine impfquote wie
in skandinavien oder an anderen ländern
hätten hätten wir auch andere
möglichkeiten diese möglichkeit zur
eigenverantwortung die gibt es ja bei
uns und leider hat ein zu großer teil
der bevölkerung aus meiner persönlichen
sicht davon genau in die falsche
richtung gebrauch gemacht nämlich neben
sinne nein wir wollen uns nicht impfen
lassen mit dem ergebnis dass aber auch
der geimpfte teil der bevölkerung
durchaus dann wieder im risiko drin
steht das sehen wir ja in den vielen
durchbrüchen und deswegen ist das eine
einfache sache eigenverantwortung ist
vor allen dingen dann prima wenn man
sich als teil einer gemeinschaft sieht
das tun natürlich auch die meisten
menschen und wir haben ja alle die
erfahrung gemacht und nun schon zum
dritten mal dass die menschen in diesem
land immer schon vor den politischen
entscheidungen sich anders verhalten
haben und eigentlich hätte man daraus ja
dann auch schlussfolgern können dass die
leute gar nicht so doof sind und dass
sie vor allen dingen auch in eine
richtung denken der politik wir wandern
langsam zum ende der sendung die
menschen sehnen sich nach klaren
ansagen auch nach klaren vorgaben der
politik sie sehnen sich auch nach einem
ende glauben sie aber sie sehnen sich
auch nach einem politischen
überbietungswettbewerb
nein das glaube ich nicht ich glaube wir
sehen uns alle nach dem gleichen ein
stück normalität die freiheit wieder zu
haben diesen kurs glaube ich wollen wir
alle gemeinsam gehen und ich denke da
sind die länder sich auch einige wir
müssen aber trotzdem noch vorsichtig
bleiben aufpassen und der virus ist auch
nicht an einem bestimmten tag weg aber
ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir da in
eine gute zukunft gehen zurück samen
chef von omikron zu dem pandemie also zu
einem zu einer ende mai wird kann man an
welchen kriterien dann ablesen naja das
ist eben geringere ausbrüche und auch
lokal beschränkte ausbrüche gibt aber
wie gesagt so weit sind wir noch nicht
weltweit ich würde gerne aber noch einen
punkt der mir auf der seele liegt
ansprechen wir haben eben über 200 tote
antrag und der staat hat ja auch die
verpflichtung die körperliche
unversehrtheit zu schützen warum sind
diese toten inzwischen unwichtig
geworden am anfang der pandemie waren
sie wichtig für staatliches handeln und
jetzt plötzlich guckt man nur nach denen
diesen den stationen ob die überlaufen
oder nicht das kommt mir sehr unlogisch
vor in der ganzen argumentation ich mein
ich bin kein verfassungsjurist aber ich
glaube auch dass die menschen sich diese
frage stellen warum warum kann das jetzt
alles passieren und trinken andernach
wir werden herr buschmann da sagt jonas
schmidt chanasit am ende selbst das ende
der pandemie festlegen wir werden
festlegen müssen was ein akzeptables
restrisiko ist wir werden festlegen
müssen wie viele menschen sterben dürfen
und wie groß die schäden sein dürfen das
ist der ursprungsgedanke von wolfgang
schäuble glaube ich von vor anderthalb
jahren ist es so wirkt die politik
festlegen müssen welche schäden wir
hinnehmen als akzeptable schäden und das
ende festnehmen das ist auch das tun wir
nicht dazwischen gehen darf das glaube
ich auch dass wir doch einmal festlegen
müssen aber erst nachdem wir alle unsere
wissenschaftlichen möglichkeiten
ausgelotet haben und so weit sind wir
noch nicht ich sag nochmal impfstoffe
anpassen medikamente etc zur
entschuldigung
auch in erwiderung auf sie das tut mir
leid also diese reihenfolge die sie
beschrieben haben die stimmt genau nicht
sondern die begründung war immer der
schutz des gesundheitssystems und das
war der maßstab also wird das ist der
ursprünglichen maßstab und der den wir
auch jetzt anlegen müssen ich will dass
nur klarstellen weil
das auch das können sie auch so
nachvollziehen jetzt auf diese frage
natürlich ist das so denn eine
gesellschaft absoluter sicherheit kann
es nicht geben es sei denn wir würden
alle bürgerinnen und bürger in die
einzelhaft übergeben wir haben diese
frage wie stellen sie in ganz vielen
lebensbereichen wie stark regulieren wir
den straßenverkehr wie stark regulieren
wir unter alltagsleben wie tiefgreifend
ermittlungsbehörden in die privatheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger ein das ist
ein aushandlungsprozess den eine
demokratische gesellschaft führen muss
und es wird so sein wenn corona ein
phänomen ist das vergleichbar wird mit
anderen gesundheitlichen phänomenen mit
denen wir leben wird man gar nicht umhin
kommen zu sagen es ist irgendwann ein
stück alltags risiko und da gibt es
keine naturwissenschaftlichen maßstab
alleine sondern es ist ein aus handlungs
frage die in einer liberalen demokratie
auch öffentlich besprochen werden muss
deshalb ist es mir so wichtig und dass
wir das nicht tabuisiert hätte dass das
so ist ist es auch so an ist was den
euro als mediziner war es mir im alltag
in der praxis in der notaufnahme jetzt
auch wo ich ja ganz für online mache
wichtig ich kann ja nur das pferd zum
wasser führen ja das heißt ich kann den
menschen nur sagen was ist gesund aber
es ist auch völlig in ordnung wenn
jemand sagt ich entscheide mich für die
flasche bier auf dem sofa mit der tüte
chips obwohl wir wissen dass es im
lebenszeit groß ist und vincent es ist
nicht ungewöhnlich so zum beispiel kann
also ich da ja ich darf mich ja auch für
um gesundheit entscheiden deswegen ist
ja mein recht auf freiheit höher als
mein recht auf gesundheit was mir jemand
vor schreiben könnte ich darf es selbst
entscheiden mir ist nur wichtig man muss
vorher darüber gesprochen haben dass es
da nicht die römer gibt wenn es dann so
weit ist und man hat die krankheit man
hat das problem und so viel zu den
antiviralen mitteln die frau am schiff
und sie ja schon angesprochen haben alle
die sich nicht impfen lassen wollen und
sagen ich nehme dann lieber das
antivirale mittel ja und ich gehe lieber
auf die intensivstation also ich würde
ein medizinisch mich immer für die
impfung anstatt für diese tablette
entscheiden klar herrn die helfen allein
aufgrund der nebenwirkungen mit impfen
ist die esd ist die geniale idee der
medizin tausende von jahren alt
funktioniert hervorragend und hat uns
überhaupt so weit gebracht wie wir heute
sind viel lieber als in der tablette nun
mit einer anderen kampagne vielleicht
die
dann ganz andere kampagne hätten wir
auch noch mal los geschickt am ende
dieser sendung ich darf mich ganz
herzlich bedanken in zwei
himmelsrichtungen nach münchen und nach
düsseldorf und hier am tisch danken dass
wir heute beieinander waren und auch das
wieder diskutieren konnten markus lanz
ist in der spur er hat heute unter
anderem karin prien ausschließlich aus
stein zu versehen und sind sie müssen
wissen dass mieter gleiche stelle
gleiche relation sollen sie gewohnt sind
bleiben sie gesund
danke
[Musik]